traveling the world with a stranger dead
rats and the Jazz routine from hell
we're pretty sure these endings didn't
seem so disturbing in the theater
John Woo's 1997 action flick Face-Off
circles around two characters who Face
Off With Their well faces off FBI agent
Sean Archer holds a personal Vendetta
against Castor Troy a psychopathic
bomber who murdered Archer's
six-year-old son archers Vendetta drives
him to take Extreme Measures to capture
Troy and foil his plans eventually
leading him to undergo a temporary
surgery that makes him look and sound
like Troy however a string of
Unfortunate Events confines archer in
the prison he was infiltrating as Troy
allowing the real Troy to adopt Archer's
face and identity as a result Archer's
wife Eve goes through a series of
traumas at the film's climax she first
finds out that she's been living with a
sociopathic killer who she'd mistaken
for her husband and then she is held
hostage by Troy who still has Sean's
face by the way after that their
daughter Jamie is also taken hostage by
Troy in the end Sean wins back his face
and reunites with his family in reality
however it wouldn't be easy for Eve and
Jaime to immediately unsee Sean as the
murderer and sociopath that Troy was
basically that family is going to need a
whole lot of therapy
Whiplash tells the tale of an extremely
toxic teacher-student pair who go to
extreme lengths to perfect their craft
and musical talents at the expense of
their relationships family and their own
mental health throughout the film
ambitious drummer Andrew Neiman
relentlessly hammers towards his desire
for greatness fueled by his abrasive
music teacher Terence Fletcher why do
you suppose I just hurled a chair at
your head Neiman
I I don't know true you do
the tempo as a result Andrew distances
himself from his father splits up with
his girlfriend repeatedly injures his
hands from overplaying and is involved
in a near fatal car accident before
making his way to a concert the
climactic concert sequence in which
Andrew finally earns Fletcher's knot of
approval following a rigorous drum solo
gives the impression of a triumphant
ending for Andrew but with time viewers
might come to see that Andrew has
ultimately fallen into a deep pit of
suffering and self-abuse Andrew's very
likely dark path after the film's events
is hinted at by Fletcher's constant
idolization of jazz musician Charlie
Parker who himself suffered from mental
health issues and Drug addictions and
who died at age 34.
in Robert zemeckis's classic film
Forrest Gump the titular characters Many
Adventures take him all around the world
despite his low IQ Forest achieves Fame
on the football field fights in Vietnam
plays ping pong against the Chinese
receives the Medal of Honor from
president Lyndon B Johnson and reports
an office burglary that unfolds into the
Watergate scandal plus he finds himself
crossing paths with the likes of Elvis
Presley and John Lennon however its
forest's relationship with his childhood
sweetheart Jenny that serves as the
film's unifying narrative thread when
Forrest finally catches up to Ginny at
the end of the movie She reveals that
she's been infected with an unknown
virus and that she has a son who is also
named Forest Jenny succumbs to her
illness which is implied to be HIV AIDS
leaving Forrest Jr in the carav forest
senior tragically since HIV AIDS can be
transmitted from mother to child during
pregnancy it's possible that Forrest Jr
also carries the virus in a 2019
interview with Yahoo entertainment 4
Forrest Gump screenwriter Eric Roth
confirmed that the now shelved sequel
would have begun with Forrest Jr being
diagnosed with AIDS facing bullying and
discrimination in school as a result
in 50 First Dates Drew Barrymore's Lucy
struggles with the form of anterograde
Amnesia after an accident preventing her
from being able to create any memories
each day is a reset for Lucy who always
believes that it's October 13th the date
of her injury Lucy's brother and father
go to considerable efforts to recreate
the same event for her every day with
the help of the owners of a local cafe
which is where she meets Adam Sandler's
Henry Henry falls in love with Lucy and
devises a way to help her to move on to
the next day by making her watch a recap
film of her life up until the moment she
wakes up although the ending seems
perfectly wholesome and heartening the
implications are more distressing when
you really think about them Lucy who is
revealed to have a child with Henry at
the end of the film would have had to
wake up every single day for nine months
not knowing she was pregnant let alone
waking up on a boat beside a stranger
not to mention the fact that Henry is
going to have to spend most of his life
painstakingly editing and updating her
recap videos it's not exactly ideal the
plot of Toy Story culminates with Woody
and Buzz joining forces with SIDS
mistreated and disfigured toys in order
to teach the human bully a lesson as Sid
is about to send Buzz flying into the
air using a firework Woody speaks to Sid
directly through his pre-programmed
voice box seriously deviating from his
usual lines
this acts as a cue for since toys to
crawl up to him slowly in creepy Night
of the Living Dead fashion heightening
sits horror the scene reaches its apex
when Woody bursts out from his toy form
and tells Sid so play nice
Sid screams and runs away as the toys
rejoice in their Newfound Freedom great
right well while Sid getting his long
overdue comeuppance seems fitting for a
kids movie adults will notice that Sid
now has to live with the guilt of having
tortured living things since toys are
constantly present in our culture
existing in nearly every home and Retail
establishment seeing a seemingly
innocent little toy will most likely
trigger painful reminders for him
reminders that these things are actually
sentient what makes it worse is that Sid
can't talk to anyone about it since no
one would ever believe him it's a pretty
cruel fate especially considering he
never thought he was hurting anyone in
the first place
big follows 12 year old Josh Baskin a
boy whose wish to grow big comes true
when he grows into an adult body
overnight since his mother doesn't
believe that this 30 year old man is
indeed her son Josh moves to New York
City and gets an entry-level job at a
prominent toy manufacturing company
that's where he impresses owner Mr
McMillan with his insight into current
toys and his childlike enthusiasm soon
Josh is promoted to vice president of
product development along the way Josh
develops a romantic relationship with
co-worker Susan Lawrence which Fades
away as our protagonist finds adulthood
more and more exhausting eventually he
wishes to become a child again despite
Susan's initial disbelief she is
ultimately convinced that Josh is a
child and she bids a tearful goodbye at
the end of the film as she drops him at
his home worryingly the Revelation that
Josh was a 12 year old child all along
doesn't cause Susan any distress at any
time during the movie's ending which is
especially odd considering that she had
previously spent the night at apartment
the fact that she still Harbors love for
Josh at the end of the film as well as
her total lack of regret over having
been intimate with him indicate
something seriously wrong with Susan
Ratatouille is the tale of Remy the rat
the only rodent among his clan with a
taste for good food a series of events
causes Remy to become separated from his
family and the ambitious rat finds
himself in Paris om de gustos the
restaurant of Remy's cooking Idol August
Gusto here he befriends the clumsy but
sweet Alfredo linguine who Remy uses as
a human conduit to channel his culinary
talents eventually Gusto's regains its
lost reputation and opens the door to
Remy's own Bistro La Ratatouille granted
a rat becoming a chef is an amusing
premise for a Pixar movie but perhaps
not so much for real life given that the
average lifespan of a rat is two years
and Remy seems to be well into his
adulthood it's very likely that Remy
will pass away less than a year after
the film's ending since his newly opened
Bistro La Ratatouille hinges on his
culinary prowess it's not exactly ideal
for The Bistro's management and
investors that its head chef won't live
past a year then again we're talking
about a rat that can cook understand
English and control a human being like a
puppet by pulling on his hair maybe we
can give Pixar the benefit of the doubt
and assume rats live longer in the
Ratatouille universe
at the end of Back to the Future Marty
McFly returns from 1955 to an altered
1985 where his family's personalities
have done a complete 180. his father
seems to be much more confident and has
built a successful writing career his
mother seems healthy and happy in her
marriage his brother has a well-paying
job and his sister has quite the act of
dating life Great Scott on the surface
this seems like the best possible future
for anyone to return to however because
Marty still remembers events from the
earlier timeline his new family members
are total strangers to him this means
that he'll have to deal with the
knowledge of his parents prior
personalities without being able to
discuss it with anybody it's also
unsettling to consider that if Marty
perhaps created the new timeline his
parents in the original timeline may
still be waiting for him to return if
they haven't been written out of time
entirely additionally the family now
employs Biff as a valet seemingly
forgetting that 30 years ago on the
night of the prom dance Biff tried to
force himself onto Lorraine forcing
George to come to the rescue that can't
be the most comfortable situation for
poor Lorraine
[Music]